[Música]
mateo autor compositor cantante y
revelación a radio canadá en música del
mundo 2020 2021 cordial saludo
cuál es su presentación sota más o menos
ya suites islas gracias cómo estás
bueno pues será bien para no preocuparte
mateo primero que todo felicitación por
este por esta distinción muchísimas
gracias estoy súper contento me siento
así como súper orgulloso y bueno es el
feliz de ser parte de esta comunidad de
artistas y tan bonita y de este premio
que nos ayuda pues a seguir a seguir
como creyendo lo que hacemos
entonces pues súper contento
y que representa para ti esa distinción
que representa para ti ese premio mateo
pues más allá de bueno de primero ser
como un
un pilar en la carrera digámoslo que es
un primer paso hacia hacia los objetivos
que queremos contar el equipo también
significa como una oportunidad para
decirle a todos los creadores autónomos
que están por ahí que todos los
esfuerzos valen que las horas que pasan
haciendo cosas pueden que no son en vano
porque a veces uno había mucho en la
incertidumbre de cómo uno hace las cosas
o cómo uno pasa el tiempo respecto a
alarte que no hace y bueno creo que es
importante para mí darle ese mensaje a
toda la gente de que ya todos los
creadores jóvenes sobre todo que si se
puede y que pues con mucho trabajo y con
dedicación es cosas pueden ser super
lindo después a las que todavía hablando
de jóvenes mateo tú a qué edad te
iniciaste en la música que te atrajo de
la música
bueno mi relación con la música empezó a
los 5 años en una escuela de música
folclórica latinoamericana que se llama
nueva cultura en bogotá mis papás me
inscribieron ahí muy joven que tenía 45
años y empecé a tocar ahí pues no sé
yendo cada semana y eso y con ellos
empezamos a tener un trabajo bien bonito
y gire en latinoamérica con nueva
cultura cuando fui muy joven como a los
8 años al paciente después fue una
formación académica en la música
bastante a temprana edad que me hizo
simplemente a enamorarme es después
y tocar que aprendiste de algún
instrumento en particular de salud
en la cultura arrancamos el arranque
tocando 44 venezolano
y es una caña que lleva más que todo
hacia hacia instrumentos
latinoamericanos de producción y todo lo
que es percusión canto y cuerdas lo vi
en un mismo en un mismo paquete con
ellos tenían las clases arranqué tocando
4 luego arranque pues con clases de
canto con ellos luego pasé a la guitarra
clásica en guitarra clásica estuve hasta
los 12 años casi 13 años igual con
percusión y contras de canto y después
de los 13 años me puse a
a tocar guitarra eléctrica entonces pasé
a la guitarra eléctrica ya hacer mucho
rock and roll y ya cantar además que
todo es el proceso
mateo y que te trajo a canadá
porque de salir de colombia a que sí
salí me acuerdo aún tenés avión a los 19
años tenía 19 años
y fue porque yo hice la música siempre
de chico parte de mí es como inerte es
algo que es inerte a mateo digamos
entonces
cuando terminé mis estudios en el
colegio decidí estudiar en escenografía
en teatro para diseño de producciones
escénicas de espectáculo en vivo en las
alcoholes en bogotá
cuando terminé mis estudios yo quería
ser bueno y si lo hice quería hacer una
especialización en iluminación en vídeo
y en sonido más la parte técnica porque
no tenía los conocimientos técnicos sino
que más que todo de diseño entonces
decidí venir a montreal por eso y para
aprender francés también y bueno quiero
expandir mi carrera quiero
especializarme pero fue más que todo por
por mientras carreras que es en
dirección técnica y en diseño de
iluminación para espectar columbia
y esta y trabajas en esta parte digamos
porque me imagino que como cantante como
autor compositor estás ocupado también
trabajas en teatro bien si también ha
sido un equilibrio bastante bastante
interesante porque pues yo estoy
bastante en escena pero también detrás
de la escena antes me permite tener como
una visión global del asunto
entonces si he trabajo mucho en la
música pero al mismo tiempo trabajo para
compañías de danza contemporánea soy
director técnico para una compañía que
se llamaban game of six y estuve en
otros proyectos con compañías como
andino que hago diseño como set design
que es como escenografía para para
conciertos para proyectos para
videoclips trabajo más que todo en el
sector y común como técnico y como
director técnico ahorita más que todo
entonces
es bastante mucha presión y estoy
bastante conforme de siempre
bien te mando me imagino me imagino pues
que te debe mantener ocupado tu vida de
artistas justamente como cómo ha sido tu
vida de artista aquí en canadá desde que
llegaste fácil difícil como la ves tú
dos estadios
esta siempre ha sido bastante largo
bastante se ha tenido mucha suerte
digamos pero también las oportunidades
de ser buscado yo mismo y ha sido un
camino largo digamos lo que llevo aquí
cinco años
[Música]
y no parece mucho pero de camella un
montón para para poderme como instalar
en la escena lo que empecé a hacer acá
fue ir a ver muchos conciertos fui a ver
muchísimos conciertos al principio mente
de todos toda la escena que quería ver y
así con mini mini momentos de que no son
coincidencias pero tomé como las
oportunidades que los conciertos me
daban para poder exponer mi talento
porque la única manera en la que uno
puede conectar con la gente es mostrar
lo que no hace entonces pues digamos lo
que soy bastante determinado y tengo
como como nos tienen que dar en el
sentido entonces pues
un largo proceso y no fue fácil para
nadie acá solo sin nadie no tenía
contacto ni a nadie con dos maletas
trabajen de todo
y estudiando puliendo me yendo a ver
conciertos conociendo gente proponiendo
cosas y bueno viendo el universo también
pues yo no atrae uno termina trayendo
todo entonces pues no lo fija así pero
ha sido ha sido súper lindo algún tiempo
mi concierto súper privilegiado ha
tenido mucha suerte también entonces
pues eso ha sido como lo bonito cómo
recoger frutos después de haber cambiado
tanto lo mateo y sigue cantando con
lengua ya salsa brava
con lengua ya si estoy todavía cantando
con ellos estamos realizando el segundo
álbum de la orquesta
y si todavía todo bien te sigo sigo
cantando con ellos ellos han sido una
parte bien fundamental de mi carrera que
en canadá
y bueno este proyecto nació también
porque quería encontrar mi propia voz
más allá de estar en estar proyectando
al proyecto estado como en varios
proyectos estos últimos años que hace
parte de lo que soy como músico es
guitarrista de jazz para para otros
proyectos he sido cantante salsa luego
soy cantante rock o compositor para esto
para lo otro rap o lo que sea entonces
pues ahorita haber lanzado mateo
significa haber encontrado mi sonido y
haber encontrado como él la voz digamos
la vía artística y una personalidad una
identidad en mi música y eso pues me lo
permitió venga ya y todos los grupos en
los que estaba
y esta es la vida que vas a seguir ahora
ahora que eres revelación radio canadá
2020 2020 que si si la idea es explotar
eso la idea es seguir aprendiendo sobre
todo porque este es un camino del que
uno no termina de aprender y sobre todo
la idea de este proyecto también es
además de proponer un producto sueño
fresco y que sea accesible para la gente
es también demostrar que que canadá
tiene mucha riqueza musical que todos
somos parte de ella todos los artistas
de acá porque yo también me siento un
artista
montreal es canadiense y que tiene mucha
influencia de esta ciudad también más
allá de mi herencia cultural en mi
origen
creo que también es importante que
canadá o la comunidad tenga un sentido
de pertenencia hacia asia los artistas
que están haciendo cosas increíbles acá
y que son bastantes entonces para mí es
la oportunidad de seguir con el combate
así 100% y hacer que la gente también
cambió un poco la imagen que tiene la
música latina que es bien homogenizada y
que pues es algo nuevo es algo fresco y
que puedes notar candela y desear
te lo deseo mateo ya para terminar
cuáles son los proyectos para el futuro
ahora
bueno ahora cada crisis es una
oportunidad no entonces pues digamos lo
que fue bastante desestabilizante para
para el proyecto digámoslo el hecho de
estar sin sin shows sin conciertos
porque pues el plan el año pasado
trabajamos un montón para que este año
simplemente fuera tocar pero con esta
situación lo que vemos para el futuro es
mucha producción mucha creatividad
entonces pues estamos en un proceso de
composición de hacer un álbum digámoslo
la idea es terminar y le pide sale pero
tiene cinco canciones que lo saque pero
la ideas es de pronto 10 11 canciones
para hacer un álbum de verdad entonces
entrar en estudio con la banda seguir
ensayando seguir puliendo las los
músicos porque yo tengo seis músicos
detrás mío
tengo un equipo de producción que ha
sido súper súper como su por efe
entonces eso es súper cool vamos a hacer
vídeos vamos a hacer fotos vamos a dar
por hecho tener el máximo de material
que podamos hacer en el proyecto para
para que se vea bonito y para atacar
cuando las cosas de pronto cambien no
bueno pues seguro que va a cambiar esto
no puede continuar así toda la vida
mateo y te gustaría agregar algo en
particular antes de terminar esta
entrevista sí claro que sí bueno es más
que todo lo que yo decía al comienzo yo
creo que es muy importante y bueno son
dos cosas la primera es que no dejemos
de creer como artistas a la gente que va
a escuchar esta entrevista lo que sean
los artistas y la gente que tiene
proyectos personales así no sean
pintores músicos sino que tengan
proyectos personales no dejen de creer
porque es lo único que los va a seguir
como guiando en esto y que va a dar
fruto si usted no va a hacer las cosas
bien un oleaje bien y pues si no que no
es para uno pues el universo se va a
cargar de de quitárselo y lo segundo es
esto de apropiarse de los músicos que
están haciendo cosas acá de los artistas
para toda la comunidad latino que cuando
yo por tu lesión y quiso y si me parece
importante
que nos apropiamos de los artistas que
tenemos acá y que estén súper pendientes
de lo que se viene con mateo tenemos
muchas sorpresas vamos a seguir
produciendo música y esto es sólo el
comienzo
mateo autor compositor cantante hombre
de teatro y revelación radio canadá de
música del mundo 2020 2021 muchísimas
gracias por esta entrevista a radio
canadá internacional muchísimas gracias
pablo y muchísimas gracias por apoyarnos
así porque es muy muy importante en
estos momentos yo estoy muy agradecidos
no es como hay gracias en serio es es un
privilegio poder ser parte de este
espacio y bueno sigamos creando sigamos
construyendo la cultura de este país y
sigamos exponiendo lo que somos
[Música]